everything bill bryson sets out to
explore the great mysteries of the
universe from the smallest cork to the
largest galaxy this talk from the
national press club in washington DC is
about 50 minutes good evening and
welcome to Olsen's reading series at the
national press club tonight we're
delighted to have bill bryson back with
us mr. Bryson is perhaps best known for
his travel books in these we've
accompanied him in search of small town
America learned about the adduced sink
receives of the Brits mmm hike the
Appalachian Trail and discovered the
numerous species of killer wildlife in
Australia all without leaving the
comforts of home in his latest book a
short history of nearly everything he
takes this far beyond this planet and
introduces us to the universe a new york
times book critic has said that this
book seems destined to become a modern
classic of science writing i think he
could be right to tell us all about it
please welcome Bill Bryson
thank you very much thank you jan is
this coming through ok for people to
back ok no no there's that better okay
um what just shout out if it if it stops
being audible and it's great to be back
in Washington and I'm very grateful to
all of you for turning up tonight and
for all sins for having me back again
all since it's been very good to me for
a long time and I'm extremely grateful
to them you know it wasn't all that long
ago that I did a reading to a group of
just five people at a barnes & noble not
too far from here out in Virginia of
whom one of the five people was the
manager of the store so clearly she
wasn't good to make any purchases and
two others were were friends of my
parents who had retired to Roanoke and
really only wanted to know how my mom
and dad were now the fourth guy this is
absolutely true the fourth guy was a
person who was also named Bill Bryson
who thought this was so fabulously
comical that he had driven all the way
left quite a distance sir so that we can
stand together and look at his driver's
license symbol confirmed that we did
indeed hysterically share the same name
and the fifth person was his wife so
what I find myself in front of a group
like this it's just both startling and
very gratifying and so I have genuinely
very grateful to but it's also it's
deeply unnerving I have to tell you
because I'm always afraid when I get up
in front of a group of people like this
that they might expect me to say
something important or even profound and
I've never been very good at
profundities I have to tell you I get
asked profound questions all the time
but I just seemed always to blurt out
the wrong kind of answer the last time I
can remember I had to do an author
questionnaire for a publication of WH
Smith which is a British bookstore chain
and one of the questions on the
questionnaire was what would you like
people to be saying about you a hundred
years from now which is quite a tough
question and I thought really hard about
the answer and the answer I gave was an
amazing thing is he
still sexually active
um
but having said that I do have to try to
be a little more profound than usual
tonight because because the book i'm
here to present to you is so this this
one's called the short history of nearly
everything and it is a slightly more
somber and serious book but before i do
that i would be very grateful if you'd
indulge me in something else it's not
often that I get to get up in front of a
group as as good-looking and influential
as this and a few years ago in my
capacity as self-appointed conscience of
the universe I announced a new program
of rules for the planet and a very
disappointed to tell you that these has
not yet been widely adopted anywhere so
I just thought when I had such a nice
group here tonight I would like if I
made to reintroduce them again in the
hope that you will take them out and
spread them through the world there are
only 12 of these rules but they're very
very important to me and I would be very
grateful sincerely grateful if you would
take them all to heart in order to make
the world a better place the following
rules will take force with immediate
effect across the planet one it is no
longer permitted to be stupid and slow
you must choose one of the other two
people who are articles of clothing
which the manufacturer's name or logo is
prominently displayed must also we're
bad saying yes I am an idiot three when
standing in line to purchase food or
beverages anyone has to leave the line
to ask his or her partner whether the
partner wants a sugar cone or plane cone
or chocolate powder on their cappuccino
or cinnamon stick or anything like that
will be escorted from the premises
anyone who reaches the front of the line
and says that what do I want and purses
his lips thoughtfully and drums his
fingers on his chin while studying the
ordering options as if for the first
time will be taken outside and shot for
any electronic clock or other timing
device so it's the time is set by
holding down the button and scrolling
laborious Lee through the minutes and
hours is illegal also when you're trying
to set the alarm on such a device for
say seven a.m. and the numbers get to
about 6 56 and then suddenly speed up
and you discover to your dismay that
you've gone past the desired hour and
have to start all over again that is
extremely illegal five photocopiers will
clearly indicate where you are supposed
to put the piece of paper you want
photocopied and will provide an
immediate refund and spoken apology each
time they produce a horizontal photocopy
when a vertical one is desired thank you
any user of a photocopier who instructs
the machine to produce a tablecloth size
photocopy a 100 copies of a single
document or anything like that who then
does not reset the machine to its normal
service will be hunted down by the
photocopier police and made to drink a
cup of toner 6 all cars will come
equipped with gas caps on both sides all
gas station hoses will be at least 6
feet longer 7 if you are a repairman it
is henceforth against the law to expect
me to know where anything is I cannot
show you the location the fuse boxes
stop [ __ ] shut off valves outflow
channels compressors outlet manifold or
anything with the word sump in it 8
supermarkets henceforth are required to
put everything where a middle-aged man
who doesn't shop much confined it 9 in
office buildings and other premises in
which entry is through double doors and
one of those doors is locked for no
reason the door must bear a large sign
saying this door is locked for no reason
10 with immediate effect the following
are illegal tofu low-fat cheese
pronouncing etc as if it had a k in it
saying in any circumstances that you are
seeking closure thinking that if you put
a little bit of food that I really don't
want to eat on the end of a fork and
waving it in my face it will somehow
become attractive to me and all medical
procedures ending in the word Oscar p11
all reviews of mr. Bryson's work well
with immediate effect be submitted to
mr. Bryson for correction and helpful
revision before publication and finally
12 all Americans will appreciate irony
all Britons will understand that two ice
cubes in the drink is not nearly enough
thank you for helping to make the world
a better place your cooperation is
appreciated
now as I said I'm here to really talk
about this new book of Mines called a
short history of nearly everything and
it's not I've discovered on this book
tour I'm on um it's not a terribly zbook
to present to an audience because it
doesn't have a lot of passages that lift
neatly out and makes nice self-contained
readings and it's not even a terribly
easy book to describe I'm afraid um
because frankly it's slightly all over
the place so then it covers a lot of
territory and it kind of rambles on a
little bit in a charming way I hope but
um I think for the basically the way the
way I can best describe it is it it's
really looking at an awful lot of very
fundamental facts that are truly
astonishing when you stop to think about
them but that which we hardly ever stop
to think about it considered for
instance your own existence the fact
that you're here right now alive and in
the 21st century and you may not feel
like it but every one of you is a kind
of a little miracle in the whole history
of the universe atoms have never
assembled together before and quite the
way necessary to make you and when you
die all your little atoms will go off
and become other things and and nothing
like you will ever exist again so just
existence is itself is pretty amazing
when you stop to think about it and the
book is really is really looking at that
it's just saying how did that happen how
did I get here what was necessary for
these things to happen when you start
asking a question like that you
obviously have to keep going back and
back and back and eventually you realize
that in order to try to answer questions
of that magnitude you have to go right
back to the very beginning all the way
back to the Big Bang that started at all
so that's really why it's called a short
history of nearly everything for four
years the publishers in both New York
and London have been calling me up and
saying to me what are you doing and I
see well I don't know exactly and they
say well what's it about and I'd say
well it's about everything really or
nearly and so that's kind of where the
title came from it's more a reflection
of ISIL as much what I've done but what
it felt like I was trying to do while I
was doing it um one of the delights to
me in doing the book was discovering
that what we know what we're science has
brought us is dependent on
work of of just hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of mostly unsung people
some of whom quite delightful and just
to give you a kind of flavor I hope of
what the book is about I'd like to read
your passage about two of my favorites
they were the father and son team the
hall Danes who were active in Britain in
the early years of the 20th century and
on into the 40s and I believe into the
50s I seem to have lost the page their
speciality was a human physiology and
human tolerances for stress a great deal
of what we know about surviving at
extremes is owed to the extraordinary
father-and-son team John Scott and jbs
haldane even by the demanding standards
of British intellectuals the whole Danes
were outstanding the eccentric the
senior Halden was born in 1862 an
aristocratic Scottish family but spent
most of his career in comparative
modesty as a professor of physiology at
Oxford he was famously absent-minded
once after his wife had sent him
upstairs to change for a dinner party he
failed to return and was discovered
asleep in bed in his pajamas when roused
halt dein explained that he had found
himself disrobing and had assumed it was
bedtime his idea of a vacation was to
travel to Cornwall to study hookworm in
miners halt dein son Jack known to
posterity as jbs was a remarkable
prodigy who took an interest in his
father's work almost from infancy at the
age of three he was overheard demanding
peevishly of his dad but is it
oxyhemoglobin oxyhemoglobin or
carboxyhemoglobin throughout his youth
young Halden helped his father with
experiments by the time he was a teenage
of the two often tested gases and gas
masks together taking it in turns to see
how long it took each of them to pass
out
whereas his father's principal interests
concerned minors and poisoning the
younger halt dein became obsessed with
saving submariners and divers from the
unpleasant consequences of their work
with Admiralty funding he acquired a
decompression chamber that he called the
pressure pot this was a metal cylinder
into it's three people at a time could
be sealed and subjected to tests of
various types all painful and nearly all
dangerous volunteers might be required
to sit in ice water while breathing
Aaron atmosphere or subjected to Jane to
dangerously rapid changes of
pressurization in one experiment halt
dein simulated dangerously hasty ascent
to see what would happen what happened
was that the dental fillings in his
teeth exploded almost every experiment
writes one chronicler ended with someone
having a seizure bleeding or vomiting
the chamber was virtually soundproof so
the only way for occupants to signal and
happiness or distress was to tap
insistent Lee on the chamber wall or to
hold up notes to a small window on
another occasion while poisoning himself
with elevated levels of oxygen halt dein
had a fit so severe that he crossed
several vertebrae collapsed lungs were a
routine hazard perforated eardrums were
quite common to but as halt dein
reassuringly noted in one of his essays
the drum generally heels up and differ
hole remains in it although one is
somewhat deaf one can blow tobacco smoke
out of the ear in question which is a
social accomplishment what was
extraordinary about this was not that
Halden was willing to subject himself to
such risk and discomfort in the pursuit
of science but that that he had little
trouble talking colleagues and loved
ones into climbing into the chamber to
sent on a simulated descent his wife
once had to fit that lasted 13 minutes
when at last she stopped bouncing across
the floor she was helped to her fate and
sent home to cook dinner Paul did
happily employed whoever happened to be
around including on one memorable
occasion the former prime minister of
Spain Juan Negron who happened to be
visiting dr. Negron complained afterward
of minor tingling and a curious velvety
sensation on the lips but otherwise
seems to have escaped unharmed he may
have considered himself very lucky
indeed a similar experiment with oxygen
deprivation
left hauled in without feeling in his
buttocks and lower spine for six years
and one of the other things I discovered
was that also what we know is is
dependent very vey to a very
extraordinary degree on people would be
willing to subject themselves to great
danger and privation high risk and to
work for years sometimes just to add a
little nugget of additional knowledge to
the body that's already known and I
don't think there was a better example
of this in the whole of science history
then in the 18th century when people
suddenly became obsessed with this with
this desire to start measuring the earth
and working out exactly the dimensions
of the earth to work out how big it was
around and how much it weighed and where
exactly it stood in space and in this
18th century in the middle decades at
18th century they realized that if they
did something if they charted a
phenomenon known as a transit of Venus
which is simply when the planet Venus
passes across the face of the Sun that
if they charted this from enough spots
on earth and and carefully compared
notes they could triangulate the
distance of birth is from the Sun and
from that work out how far the earth is
from the moon and all the other
celestial known celestial bodies and and
suddenly know for the first time exactly
where we were in space and how big space
was at least the part of it that we can
see around us so it's a really exciting
moment the trouble was the transits of
Venus come in pairs eight years apart
and then and then are absent for a
century or sometimes much more we didn't
have any in the 20th century for
instance the next one will be next year
in 2004 so that's the background to this
when they started looking for transits
of Venus with the instinct for a deal
that characterized the age scientists
set off for more than 100 locations
around the globe to Siberia China South
Africa Indonesia and the woods of
Wisconsin among many others France
dispatched 32 observers Britain 18 more
and and still others were set out from
Sweden Russia Italy Germany Ireland into
elsewhere it was history's first
cooperative international
scientific venture and almost everywhere
it ran into problems many observers were
waylaid by war or sickness or shipwreck
others made their destinations but open
their crates to find equipment broken or
warped by tropical heat once again the
French seemed fated to provide the most
memorably unlucky participants
jean-jacques spent months travelling to
siberia by coach boat and slay nursing
his delicate instruments over every
perilous bump only defined the last
vital stretch blocked by swollen rivers
the result of unusually heavy spring
rains which the locals were Swift to
blame on him after they saw him pointing
strange instruments of the sky chap
managed to escape with his life but with
no useful measurements unluckier still
was beyond lashauwn teal whose
experiences are wonderfully summarized
by timothy ferriss in the book coming of
age in the Milky Way lejon teo set off
from france a full year ahead of time to
observe the transit from india but
various setbacks on route left him still
at sea on the day of the transit just
about the worst place to be since steady
measurements were impossible on a
pitching ship undaunted or perhaps just
mildly daunted lejon teal continued on
to india to await the next transit eight
years later in 1769 with eight years to
prepare he erected a first-rate viewing
station tested and retested his
instruments and had everything in a
state of perfect readiness on the
morning of the 2nd transit June the 4th
1769 he awoke to a fine day but just as
Venus began its past a cloud slid in
front of the Sun and remained there for
almost exactly the duration of the
transit three hours 14 minutes and seven
seconds stoic Leela's on teal packed up
his instruments and set off for the
nearest port but enroute he contracted
dysentery and was laid up for nearly a
year still weakened he finally made it
onto a ship it was nearly wrecked in a
hurricane off the African coast when at
last he reached home 11 and a half years
after setting off and having achieved
nothing he discovered that his relatives
it had him declared dead in his absence
and had enthusiastically plundered his
estate
well I won't I want to try my luck or
your patients by really too much more
but I will read you just one more
passage if if I may I started off by
talking about how miraculous it is that
we are all assemblages of atoms and that
they somehow this marvelous cooperative
venture to give us life but that's only
part of it so thank goodness for atoms
but the fact that you have atoms and
that they assemble in such a willing
manner is only part of what got you here
to be here now alive in the 21st century
and smart enough to know it you also had
to be the beneficiary of an
extraordinary string of biological good
fortune survival on earth is a
surprisingly tricky business of the
billions and billions of species of
living things that have existed since
the dawn of time most 99.99 percent are
no longer around life on Earth you see
is not only brief but dis mainly ten
years it is a curious feature of our
existence that we come from a planet
that is very good at promoting life but
even better at extinguishing it the
average species on earth on earth last
for only about four million years or so
it's thought so if you wish to be around
for billions of years you must be as
fickle as the atoms that made you you
must be prepared to change everything
about yourself shape size color species
affiliation everything and to do so
repeatedly that's much easier said than
done because the process of change is
entirely random to get from protoplasmic
primordial atomic globule as the Gilbert
and Sullivan song put it to sentient
upright modern human has required you to
mutate new traits over and over in a
precisely timely manner for an
exceedingly long while so at various
periods of the last 3.8 billion years or
so you have abhorred oxygen and then
doted on it grown fins and limbs and
jaunty sales laid eggs flicked the air
with a forked tongue then sleep then
furry lived underground lived in trees
then as big as a dare in the smallest
mouse and a million things more the
tiniest deviations from any of these
evolutionary shifts and you might now be
licking algae from cave walls or lolling
walrus like on some stony Shore or just
gorging air through a boat a blowhole
on the top of your head before diving 60
feet for a mouth full of delicious
sandworms not only have you been lucky
enough to be attached since time
immemorial to a favorite evolutionary
line but you've also been extremely make
that miraculously fortunate in your
personal ancestry consider the fact that
for 3.8 billion years a period of time
older than the Earth's mountains and
rivers and oceans every one of your
forebears on both sides has been
attractive enough to find a mate healthy
enough to reproduce and sufficiently
blessed by fate and circumstances to
live long enough to do so not one of
your pertinent ancestors was squashed
devoured drowned starves stranded stuck
fast untimely wounded or otherwise
deflected from its life's quest of
delivering the tiny charge of genetic
material to the right partner at the
right moment in order to perpetuate the
only possible sequence of hereditary
combinations that could result
eventually astoundingly and all too
briefly in you now I know that is asking
a lot for people to pay twenty seven
dollars and fifty cents but book on the
basis of such a flying visit to its
contents but happily I'm delighted to
tell you that I have been authorized by
my publisher to make a special offer
here tonight which is by the book for
the asking price of twenty seven dollars
and fifty cents take it home and read it
and if after seven days you're not fully
satisfied you may keep the book
yeah I have two other things I want to
do one it needed to do with the book
exactly before I start taking questions
one is some I I asked my son I have a 24
year old son who read the book and
pronounces a good book he was pleased
with it and I said to him after he
dreaded I said well um well you know I'm
going on a book tour with what shall I
what shall I read to audiences
what'swhat's I tell them about the book
and he said tell them the bear story dad
which was interesting because there is
no bear story in this book and what he
meant was telling the best way I used to
tell when I was out promoting another
book called a walk in the woods so I
will tell you the bear story and the
bear story simply that when I was hiking
the Appalachian Trail as you'll know if
you read a walk in the woods I grew
somewhat preoccupied with the dangers of
bear attacks and I was very gratified to
discover after the book came out that
lots and lots of other people all across
North America share these concerns
because I got letters literally by the
sackful from people giving me advice on
how to avoid bear attacks while hiking
and here the basic advice seems to be to
always go hiking with someone who can't
run as fast as you can
but there was one letter I got from a
lady in New Hampshire where I now live
that particularly pleased me she told me
when you go hiking out west in grizzly
bear country and grizzly bears are of
course very dangerous animals there are
two things they tell you you should do
they tell you that first of all you
should wear little bells on your
clothing because this actually alerts
the Bears you're coming and you don't
ever take them by surprise and the
second thing they tell you you should do
is watch out wherever you go for grizzly
bear scat or dung and the way you can
recognize with the bear scat is that it
has little bells in it
thank you
now I told my son I didn't think that
would sell many copies in the new book
but he said to tell you anyway now the
last thing i wanted i wanted to do just
so we don't you don't think that I've
become too solemn and in my old age is M
I'd like to read you a passage for no
reason at all it's from a book called
neither here nor there which is nothing
at all to do with the universe and how
it was created and all that and the book
is in fact about traveling around europe
i wrote it a long time ago but in fact
the passage i want to read you has
nothing to do with that either it's it's
actually just why dogs don't like me I
don't know why it is but something about
me insights dogs to a frenzy I would be
a rich man if I had a nickel for every
time a dog tried to get at the marrow in
my ankle bone while the owner just stood
there and said well I don't understand
it he's never done anything like this
you must have said something to him that
always knocks me out what would I say to
the dog hello boy like to open a vein in
my leg the only time a dog will not
attack me with a view to putting me in a
wheelchair is when I'm a guest at
someone's house sitting on a deep sofa
with a drink filled to the brim in this
case the dog and it's always a large dog
with a saliva problem but the side he
doesn't want to kill me but to have sex
with me come on bill get your pants off
I'm hot he seems to be saying the owner
always says is he bothering you I can
put him out if he's bothering you hey I
want to reply don't put him out put him
down it wouldn't bother me in the least
all the dogs in the world were placed in
a very large sack and taken to some
distant Island Greenland Springs
attractively to mine where they could
romp around and sniff each others anuses
to their heart's content and never ever
bother or terrorized me again the only
kind of dog i would excuse from this
roundup is poodles poodles I would shoot
to my mind the only possible pet is a
cow-house love you they're harmless they
look nice they don't need a box to
defecate in they keep the grass down and
they are so trusting and stupid that you
cannot help but lose your heart to them
where i live in Yorkshire there's a herd
of cows down the lane you can stand by
the field wall at any hour of the day or
night and after minute the cows will all
waddle over and stand with you much too
stupid to know what to do next but happy
just to be with you they will stand
there all day as far as I can tell
possibly till the end of time they will
listen to your problems and never ask a
thing in return they will be your
friends forever and when you get tired
of them you can kill them and eat them
perfect thank you all very very much
thankful
I would be very happy to answer
questions if anyone has ma'am yes I
would like to know what prompted you to
undertake this book that you have just
written a song on it was it was it was a
strange process I mean I always felt I
was you know in any science class in
high school junior high or college or
whatever there's always people divided
up into two groups asst there's those
people who understand instantly and
intuitively what the teacher is talking
about have a scientific bent to them and
and often generally go off and become
scientists themselves and then there's
all the rest of us they're just thinking
what is all that about I mean it was and
I was just I was always confused by
science and really pretty much bored out
of my mind by it and but I'd always had
the suspicion that it must at some level
be interesting even to a non-scientific
sort of person like myself and you know
chemistry can't be born we are all
chemicals it's got to be it's so you
know immediately relevant to us we're
all subject to the same physical laws so
physics must be in some sense
interesting to us and I just so I i
thought i'd really like to look into it
and see if it is first of all if i can
understand it well enough to write about
if it is interested in some way and and
and then to see if i can if i can
reproduce that in a way that would make
it engaging and entertaining to a
general audience so it was probably
desire to understand this myself and
then partly a challenge to see if I
could make a book out of it that's
usually what the process is for any book
really you you want to know about
something and then and then you want to
see if you can make it interesting and
science is just a nightmare i have to
tell you because you know it's your
instinct is a person or as a reporter is
to is to want things everything to be
simple and analogy I can use it if I
were writing about baseball what I would
do is I would read and read and read and
think that I understood some aspect of
science and then I would write I'd want
to write in baseball there are two ways
of being put out you can strike out or
you can hit a ball to a fielder who
catches it and puts you out
and then I would take that to scientific
friend and hand him this and and and say
how's that and he said oh I'm sorry it's
a lot more complicated than that you
know because you can also reach base
safely and be thrown out trying to steal
second and you can reach base a thin
before snap by following batter who who
hits a ground ball and you're forced out
at second and I presume you know that
Rabinowitz is doing some really
interesting work with dropped third
strikes at Berkeley and I'm not going
God he's you know this is much more
complicated than I ever supposed and it
was constantly having this battle to try
to talk personal to understand and to be
fair to what's what reality is but also
to try and keep it simple so it was he
was slightly a nightmare and in what I
always ended up doing was say something
light nobody knows how many ways there
are to be put out in baseball so anyone
else I'm just hearing since you brought
up your book a walk in the woods someone
that I told that I was coming here had
also read it and she wondered what
happened to your companion and then oh
yeah cats I'm delighted to tell you the
cats went back to Des Moines at the end
of the summer and that he's been great
he's terrific he got a job working for a
satellite printing plant for The Wall
Street Journal working on the Midwestern
addition / do that which produces
Midwestern edition of The Wall Street
Journal he met really really lovely lady
friend that he's been with for some
years now and she's wonderful because
she's cats is really big I mean he is
really quite quite quite a composition
and and cheese it changed quite small
and wiry and he's absolutely petrified
over and it's just really very dizzy i'm
indoors her she's great but but she can
boss him around and it's really
wonderful to see and he's not drinking
so his doing extremely well I just saw
him last week in Des Moines because on
this book too i went to Des Moines and
he was he's fine we went out to dinner
his great very happy and people always
said we had what did he think of the
book and it's a really interesting thing
because I want I was very worried you
know because I did make a lot of jokes
at his expense in the book
and and I didn't know how he'd take it I
mean I know he's a very good sport but
it was asking a lot at times and he
loved the book I mean he really seems to
like the book and and i discovered
belatedly i discovered to my surprise
that the reason he likes the books on
ice it's because he thinks it's entirely
fictitious and we had this conversation
where I've said to him you know what's I
don't understand I said you know do you
deny for instance throwing all your
stuff over the cliff edge on the first
day and he'll say well no and so would
you deny you know that I had to put your
tent up for you the first night because
you were too big a baby to do it
yourself is it one know we kind of go
through the whole book and I said well
too where's the fiction fan and he says
it's just the way you tell it especially
since we're both right yeah then just
him we went to Australia a couple of
years ago and used in a sunburned
country as our guide and so thanks to
you we merged relatively unscathed then
we went on to New Zealand and found fair
number of oddities and we're wondering
if you would consider doing a book on
New Zealand yes oddities with an animal
or human
there's actually in Rotorua which is on
the North I'd there's pipes coming out
of the back yards of each owns that are
letting off steam constantly in an
effort to not explode the entire town
because it on top of guys that right
you're totally tarnishes when you walk
through town I think you are in fact and
i can confirm that that is okay yet no I
I would love to do a book on or at least
you know make a visit to New Zealand
properly I've only ever been to New
Zealand on book tours which doesn't
count at all and I've just had little
chances to go to occasional place like
Rotorua but but i would love to go back
and do more i'm delighted to hear that
you survived australia because i get a
lot of flat because I talked australians
feel I'd dwelled over much on the
dangerous of the country and perhaps I
did but it is it is an absolute fact
that there are more things in Australia
that can hurt you and even kill you that
anywhere else I mean this is even a
caterpillar that can knock you down it
just just stroke it and you're you know
bouncing around in a minute later and
having seizures it's just most amazing
cutting and I'll straightens make it so
much worse because they're just so so
relaxed about everything and they and I
just so wonderfully laid back and
they'll tell you was a straight face
when I said you know my uncle bob was
was driving to mudgee last week and when
it when a tiger snake crawled out from
under the dashboard and bit him on the
groin really and it's all right you know
cuz he's he's out of intensive counties
no need to communicate with I blinks and
they just tell you this all the time and
then they say oh and by the way your
book would say it was much to date and
stuff it is strange so Australia is of
course a very safe country but just
watch yourself Bible in Australia which
serve as always show me very well as
touch nothing don't put your hand on a
log cuz just keep you know just keep
fake compact so just here can you
describe some unusual or IE experience
you had while researching writing this
book that didn't make it of the book but
we fell across to know
now if it'd been funny how to put it in
the book later I didn't I didn't I
really I didn't have a funny I'm sorry I
wish I had now really so back I can't
see at the back so you have to sort of
wave of a little bit of something oh
there's a rumor that you're moving back
to England and I wondered if you are and
so wha what we aren't even venting it's
not as if we suddenly become
dissatisfied with things here or exactly
it's it's no it's I mean we'd always
plan to go back to England at some point
and reasonably thought would go would
stay here for four or five years and in
fact it's now been eight years and it's
been wonderful I mean it has been
absolutely terrific we live in Hanover
New Hampshire and it's just it's a
wonderful town the people are great
we've made some wonderful friends and it
is really hard to pull ourselves away I
have become I have a hopeless affliction
i watch the Boston Red Sox in in fact
they're on espn2 now I think and I don't
know how I'm ever going to give that up
apart from apart from anything else so
it's really hard but we had reached a
point where the kids are at a position
in their development I have four
children that is a good it's either now
or wait another six years I have a son
who's 12 so it's a question of either go
back now when it's easy to comparatively
easy to reintroduce him into the British
system or let him go all the way through
the states I mean it's it's in terrible
thing I mean in a way it's a kind of
curse because we're very very attached
to two different countries and we will
probably spend our lives bouncing back
and forth between the two in some
measure we've already done that mean for
the last eight years although we you
know although we've been living in in
Hanover we spent an awful lot of time in
England would go back a lot and and the
same will be true in Reverse once we get
over there it's really only a question
of you know where i parked my car at
night but it's we still be in both
places a lot but physically yes I mean
we will be officially back in the UK and
Holly by July
so I get that toys here I get no
thinking what it was like being away
from your family the whole time during a
walk in the woods and I guess would
again and the NICU other books in a
sunburned country I do to talk about
that yeah well what's it like being away
from your family particularly walk in
the woods he said but in other books as
well it's really hard it's very hard
it's the hardest part of what I do if
that's the only really hard part of what
I do I am acutely aware that most of the
time I'm getting to do really enjoyable
things that most people spend 50 weeks
of the year saving up for to do 42 and I
get to do it all the time and call it
work and get paid for it so I'm very
lucky but the one downside is I cannot
do that without going off and leaving
home and I also very fond of my family
and I miss out on a lot of things at
home you know just kids events and and I
just things you know miss out on home
life so that's a real shame there's
nothing you can do about them and I have
to go out everybody recognizes I have to
do it but it was harder on the
Appalachian Trail than any other time
I've tried it because in the Appalachian
Trail you have all day long to do
nothing but just dwell on whatever
thoughts are going to move through your
head and it's I think it's the hardest
part about doing something like the
Appalachian Trail physically it's quite
demanding but you soon get used to that
and you actually get strong enough that
that you can you can knock off the
necessary miles without too much trouble
but the mental part i found just gets
harder and harder because there is
nothing to occupy your mind you have
nothing to think about you haven't got
any plans to make I mean normally when
you drive into work or something you're
thinking about all I must remember you
know aunt Beatrice birthday Wednesday
and you know this and that and you've
got all your life is very busy and
crowded with things the Appalachian
Trail it's you have nothing in your life
except is this this corridor through the
forest and this and this necessity of
walking along it and and so there's
nothing to think about I mean your feet
can do it for you and so it's really
strange because it's a really it's quite
satisfying in a strange way at times
because you go into the sort of Zen
space where you mind empties out
you feel very recuperated when you
finish but when you are thinking you're
just you're just thinking about all the
stuff that you would really rather be
doing this is almost anything so that's
how it was um man Christina audition
test tomorrow and I don't know why I
really do it exactly it's a 50-question
test I had no sports nah I got not one
day would you like to share your
favorite Boston Red Sox the trivia I
don't know that I know cuz I'm actually
kind of spectacularly under-informed
because we lived out of the country for
20 years and there's a whole generation
of baseball players that actually had
their whole careers and and we're
retired long enough to get into the Hall
of Fame and I don't know who they were
and it's really it's really amazing cuz
it's just like everything that happened
from from about mid 1970s until the
mid-90s is a blank to me and I sort of
have some idea of like who Reggie
Jackson was I mean because you have to
know about people like that there's a
lot of other people that I really just
have no idea what they did so even
things like Bill Buckner's famous flub
that everybody talks about the world
says I don't really know what that was
all about I mean I wasn't here for that
so no i'm sorry i don't i don't have a
good trivial I'm sorry but it wouldn't
help you with the 50 questions you're
gonna have to answer tomorrow anyway but
I do wish you every success sir I think
you the greatest job at I was on if you
can tell us a little bit about I guess
how you first got into it however said
into it well entirely by accident and my
whole life has been just one series of
accidents and which is a quite nice way
to live your life and um but what
happened was I always I grew up in a
newspaper family my parents were both
worked for the Des Moines Register and
and my brother my older brother has
several years older to me was he also
worked for the paper and so it just
seemed like that was what you did in
life you
worked on on the local paper and and in
any case some English was the only thing
I was ever any good at so I knew I'd be
working with words in some way and I
went off and became a copy editor and as
soon as I got out of college and I had
really enjoyed it and had a very happy
career doing that but in my spare time I
started writing as just as a way of
supplementing my income and and
discovered little by little that that
was a lot more fun and that the actual
moment of realization was I was doing
writing a lot of articles for TWA
in-flight magazine in the early eighties
TWA was quite successful airline at that
time and it was constantly opening up
new route cities to Europe and every
time they would do so the magazine would
send me to Frankfurt or Brussels aware
but their latest city was and I would go
into an article about and I happened to
be in Copenhagen spending five days
there walking through this delightful
Scandinavian city in springtime and and
all I had to do was was right 1200 words
they were going to pay all my expenses
and give me money on top of it and I
thought this is what I want to do
forever and and that's really the
direction I moved into them so it was
all by accident really and then little
by little I moved into books and and I
see it surges earth time your writing
style works allowed day
how I randy says well I mundane really
am I trying to I try to get really early
when I can if my wife is watching this
on c-span she's tittering now helplessly
but I try to get up she gets up very
early if so you guys have at five
o'clock I I try to get up not too much
after that because and then work because
if you work start really early in the
morning then everything is quiet to no
phone calls no distractions and it also
means that you can knock off at 2-230
the afternoon you've done you've done a
really a full day's work and you still
have all the afternoon you can you know
do things around the house or play
wiffle ball with the kids when they come
home from school or all that kind of
stuff so that's ideally what I do and I
am really in terms of the approach i use
i really just if i can I just started on
page one line one and work my way
through I then in the process you know
by the time I'm up to chapter 13 or
something I can often get stuck there
and I'll just I'll jump back to an
earlier chapter and work around on it a
little bit but I I really am sort of
desperately unimaginative I start at the
beginning and work my way towards the
finish particular the travel books sir
just here it's you in recession you go
well expect did you find the most
difficult to understand
well aspected i find it was difficult to
understand well a lot of it and I mean I
mean all of Sciences I was saying to
earlier it gets really complicated very
quickly and if you're an outsider it's
very hard to understand it and and in a
way I didn't want to understand it
versus it says I didn't want to
understand it too well because that's
always the problem with text books these
guys know what they're talking about and
and I wanted in a sensitive to be always
a little bit of I mean I wanted to be
sure I was on the right line and in the
scientists were checking the form it
would confirm that it was okay but at
the same time I did I just didn't want
to be I didn't want to be so confident
what I was writing that that I would
lose the reader and that they would be
confused by what I was writing I wanted
everybody me included to be at a certain
level of uncertainty about these things
some things were really really hard to
understand for me anything to do with
the behavior of atoms and particle
physics and and anything down in that
really really tiny level because it's so
all the way that atoms behave is so
counter-intuitive there's there's
nothing that goes on in that little
world down there that really is anything
like you you can any things don't move
around they don't occupy space in the
same way and they do things that you
know electrons can leap from one orbit
to another without actually crossing the
space in betweens what's known as the
quantum leap and these are things that
are really really hard to understand and
essentially we reached a point where you
don't understand I mean I think a lot of
particle physicist I left sort of
scratching their head about a lot of
these things I Niels Bohr a Danish
physicist once famously remarked of a
theory that question wasn't whether it
was crazy but whether it was crazy
enough and that's that's kind of what
you're dealing with it that level I was
just a couple of more questions served
in the phone the quintessential American
small town he's even be searching for a
lot oh yeah I mean the first book i did
was lost continent i went looking for
the quintessential American small town
which I ended up calling calling it
amalgam because I wasn't finding these
small town I was finding pieces of it
wherever I went and so in my mind I was
amalgamating them into this one I
idealized town
learn since moving back and looking much
more closely at the state sadar an awful
lot of really really really good towns
and we need luckily live in one I mean
Hanover New Hampshire is is I would say
is about it as ideal as a community gets
I mean it's a really really love the
attractive place but I think every place
in in America is it high risk because of
the lifestyle we choose and because what
our expectations are of what a community
should provide I mean I was in it in a
store a little shop in Hanover on Main
Street not too long ago and some woman
was bitching bit early because it had
taken her 45 minutes she said to find a
place to park and what she meant was he
taken 2 45 minutes to find a place to
park on Main Street if she's gone two
blondes she's put it parks in 30 seconds
but she would then have had to waffle it
must be said
and it's just that it's just kind of
crazy I mean we have become so so
habituated to being able to park right
outside whatever retail premises we want
and for each every retail opportunity to
have its own parking lot so that you
know you leave one place and drive 20
feet down the road and go into the next
parking lot if you're going to another
business it's just insane it's crazy I
was in Des Moines I'm sorry you have
started this is so like a story but i
just said i was in Des Moines at the
airport and I rented a car there and the
woman said to me she said I said where
do I picked up she said go outside and
get the shuttle the courtesy courtesy
shuttle bus to the parking lot and I
said this is where where is it this is
des moines I mean I this is just and she
and it was the place where the cars with
rental cars were part was about 150 feet
from the front door of the but they you
know expect you to take a shuttle to it
I just think we've got to do something
about that you have to we have to you
know if we're going to have really
attractive communities you have to you
have to pay a sacrifice in terms of
convenience that you can't have
old-fashioned communities with
old-fashioned style main streets without
having to keep the parking somehow way
from and not and getting away from this
idea that somehow all roads have to be
widened so that we can get every place
we want to get ten seconds faster I just
think that's a craziness that that this
country is still infected with anything
it's a really bad thing oh oh just a
last question sir that's enjoyable book
I've been that's a really tough one too
but I think the one that I found most
satisfying was to walk in the woods
because for all the time I was out there
in the Appalachian Trail I was thinking
um this is never this has never been a
result in a book I don't know how I'm
ever going to get a book out of it
nothing nothing was happening I mean day
after day all you're doing is the same
monotonous repetitive thing and and I
was I had no notes to take most of the
time I mean if I taken us all I could
right at the end of the day was spent
day walking
it eventually stopped and and it really
felt on inside and so all and as I was
saying earlier you know you have this
emptiness in your mind so all day long
your mind is just saying to you this is
never going to result in the book you
might as well just quit now go home see
the family you're insane bill just get
off the trail go all day long you know
eight nine hours this little voice in my
head said go oh yeah you feel terrible
get off the trail go home and so that
was when I finally got a book out of
that I was really pleased I mean when I
got off the trail obviously certain
events did occur to me that there had
been things that had happened but I can
tell you that that with with a walk in
the woods there is there is no over
matter from that book there's nothing
that happened that isn't in the board
and on that note I i guess i have to say
good night but thank you all very very
much thank you
I
bill bryson is author of a walk in the
woods I'm a stranger here myself and the
life and times of the Thunderbolt kid a
short history of nearly everything is
published